what's going on reject nation we are
going to talk about some black panther
news
which i'm to be honest still makes me a
little bit uncomfortable and and i'm
honest i'm a little bit surprised
that we're getting so much news about
black panther part two
maybe not surprising for some of you
guys for me
i i thought we wouldn't really be
hearing anything for quite quite a while
longer to be honest but
i have heard about this one so i wanted
to check out cosmic wonders video
black panther 2 will have two new black
panthers and we'll talk about it
afterwards and see we'll see what the
hell's going on
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we have
some
really big news we finally have some
type of direction that marvel studios is
going to go with
black panther 2 including when they're
going to start
filming and apparently the actor that is
going to be playing wow
it's been revealed and then in a sec
really it looks like not only are we
going to get
one black panther in the film but there
are also going to be
two new black panthers coming in black
panther too
i'll break down everything that you need
to know if you're new be sure to
subscribe
to stay up to date on all the latest
that's a sick ass
funko pop buddy very sick by heroes
hideouts.com
i'll be announcing the winner next
friday so i think a lot of us were
expecting black panther 2 to be delayed
a very long time due to the passing of
chadwick beau's course but it seemingly
appears that marvel studios
does have their plans in order and at
least have an idea of how they're going
to move forward
with the sequel now black panther 2 was
scheduled for may
6th of 2022 and although it might not be
delayed years
this may not be the release date that it
comes out but there is the possibility
that marvel studios could be sticking to
this date as today we have a report on
when the film is going to start filming
last night the internet kind of went
crazy when the hollywood reporter
reported this in an article
they said multiple sources tell the
hollywood reporter that marvel is now
readying
black panther 2 for a shoot that will
start in atlanta in july
and last six months
according to this july of 2020 it's
going to take six
months which will last until january
which would give them four months of
post production
and editing before the may release date
now that is cutting it kind of close as
far as a production schedule goes
but it can be done however if they
decide to push the remaining
few months that will kind of don't rush
this one but there were not this i want
to say
mexican actor tanak huerta who was one
of the stars on netflix's narcos mexico
is in talks to play one of the
antagonists sources tell the hollywood
reporter
now as far as which villain he could be
playing that's kind of a shot in the
dark at this point but some could argue
that he could indeed be playing
neymar the submariner at this point we
don't really have enough
information to tell but they go on to
report that latisha wright
lupita nyong'o winston duke and angelo
bessette
are expected to return for the new film
with reports stating that leticia
wright's character
shuri is going to take on a more
prominent role
now i think at this point everybody is
expecting shuri to become the new black
panther yeah this
does happen in the comics and there is a
really good way to set this up in the
movie
in the comics shari and t'challa both
challenged their uncle for the title of
black panther t'challa won but he
promised to train his sister in combat
so if a day should come when she needs
to leave wakanda she could take his
place and it does seem like that day is
going to come
sometime during black panther 2. however
we also
have a report
in a report from grace randolph she said
still hearing sherry will be black
panther alongside
a male black panther still betting it
will be a new guy in the suit
i want embaku and t'challa will get
killed at the beginning of the film
i will say if this ends up being true it
makes a lot of sense because a lot of
people
a lot of young people specify
t'challa and black panther as a role
model and it would be a shame to take
black panther away from all
those kids but at the same time having a
male black panther and then adding a
female black panther would be great
because then you would have role models
for both boys and girls so this seems
like it would be a very good strategy
for marvel and disney to do
now it has basically been confirmed by
marvel studios executive vice president
that t'challa is
actually already dead in the mcu right
whether we'll get much
explanation for that black panther 2 is
to be determined
but i for one don't think that he should
die on screen but i do like the idea of
having two
black panthers in the marvel cinematic
universe both having different roles of
course but let me know what you think
about this news
black panther 2 is going to start
filming in july which is a lot sooner
than i think
a lot of us thought it would start that
is really surprising
to play the villain and there is a
possibility that we could be getting two
black panthers so let me know what you
think about all of this news in the
comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news and black panther
2 news for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
this is weirdly a lot to wrap my head
around it really is a lot to wrap my
head around just the fact alone
they're going ahead so quickly by the
sound of this it's a lot to wrap your
head around if i'm not mistaken
the original shoot dip obviously before
chadwick bozeman's passing was supposed
to be february of i believe
2021 is when they were supposed to start
shooting there's a whole bunch of
logistics that go into
all of the all of this when it comes to
shooting schedules you got a whole team
lined up schedules blocked out for
a vast crew and cast members
of people they have their marvel slate
schedule they gotta stick to and yada
yada yada it's just that you know
like my mind goes to the fact that ryan
coogler spent
a long time developing the black panther
2 screenplay a very long time to nail
down the story and of course with
chadwick boseman passing that instantly
lands you in a case of
i need to completely change my story he
along with the rest of the people
involved
whoever was you know close with chadwick
boseman or was really affected they all
had to
take the time to grieve and then get
back to working
on what the story needs to be for a
follow-up
to me i'm like have they had enough time
to knock the
to nail that or or did they just have a
direction they're like let's just keep
developing the screenplay
until july rolls around you know when
they're talking about the shooting
schedule and
trying to land a release date which i'm
assuming will get pushed ultimately
if they're sticking to that release date
you only got four months of post i'm
like whoa
guys this is this is a movie you
shouldn't shouldn't be rushing here
yeah you want to make sure you were able
to take your time yeah exactly you don't
want to be in a position where you might
have to rush
you don't want to be cats like finishing
at 12 hours before you're screening it
yeah there's so many big moving parts
and things that could go wrong
and yeah i mean especially i think just
as human beings
towards you know the epicenter of an
event like the loss of somebody like
that who is like
the main he's the title character like
it does
i am taken aback that they would already
have some kind of plan
in motion not that the news didn't make
everybody start to speculate anyway
which is natural this feels like
a fast track which yeah is a little odd
to me it is odd and
like the idea of uh like okay villain
cool sure uh that sounds neat looks like
a latino gentleman
you know that's awesome the idea of
shuri taking over the black panther
mantle i think that's what we all
sort of expected i'm kind of wondering
if they'll even call this black panther
2
if they'll just call us something else
entirely black panthers
maybe and if there are two black
panthers i mean i hope it works with the
story context and
perhaps i might take some of the weight
and the edge off of it of someone having
to
deal with the situation of i have to
replace the shoes of chadwick boseman
carry this mantle all alone yeah so it
does take some of the weight off of that
so in that regard having two new black
panthers i think would work
really what i just care about is making
sure they have an
honorable respectable sequel follow-up
here after
such a a major passing and yeah i don't
think you need to do some cgi double
death when we're all aware of chadwick
bozeman already being gone and doing
like
cgi chat with bozeman face would be a
terrible idea
but i don't even like the idea of like
someone in a costume or doing a voice
impersonation of him like
leading with him already having passed
t'challa you might as well just
go that path since like the world
already knows it
or at most if you've got like a life
cast you know maybe
do some kind of funeral sequence where
you have his likeness
that's literally his likeness and then
you know maybe leave it at that like do
i feel like some on-screen tribute you
know and and
transition would make sense be necessary
and hopefully be
tasteful and respectful but yeah i don't
i don't want them to like animate him
and
have somebody doing mo-caps and stuff
just because
yeah i don't know especially if this is
going to arrive so
soon after chadwick boseman's passing
it's got to be
that much more on the mark of respect
yeah you know i
really think they they ought to lead
with something different like let people
know that it is black panther 2
essentially but
maybe not call it black panther 2. yeah
like just give it a give it a different
name
give it a title that involves wakanda or
something like that yeah
right now it's my focus for any news on
this is like sure if you get neymar in
there that sounds
awesome there yeah that's all cool right
now this is a
unique position for marvel to be in and
for
audience reception to be in of there's
there's a lot more eyes that are going
to be
aware of other things beyond like who's
the cool new villain or who's the cool
new black panther i think people
will have this kind of discussion on
their mind i trust marvel
to handle this properly there's any
studio whose hands that's the only
studio right now or i'm like well it's
in their hands and i trust whatever they
they're gonna do so hopefully no matter
what they still honor his legacy and i
hope this doesn't become a rush project
by all means delay it
seriously delay it yeah like i don't
care i don't think any of us would
really mind
let's just uh we just want a good film
and one that honors
uh a certain man's legacy all right guys
what do you think about this idea of
there being two new black panthers is
there a shooting schedule kind of
concern you leave your thoughts down
below you can subscribe to the real
rejects and make sure to click that
notification bell catch you guys soon